- ♪ Four and three
and two and one
- What's up, guys?
I'm Matt FX and this is
the Broad City music recap
for episode nine,
Apartment Hunters.
This is actually my last
recap for Broad City,
but it also happens to be my
favorite episode musically.
So let's just jump right in.
In this episode we
have a track called Qrs
by a mysterious new
producer called VHVL.
All I really know about her
is that her name is Veronica.
The track runs under
the really cool scene
where Alanna's getting
high in an attempt
to remember where her remote is.
And it was perfect with this
woozy, kind of flowy feeling.
(dreamy music)
- Last year,
Brooklyn, real
department of Flatbush.
Living room,
couch.
Sex on the couch.
Bad sex.
Really bad sex.
The worst sex.
Dale!
- If you check it
out on SoundCloud,
you'll see that VHVL's got
a really awesome penchant
for eerie atmospheric
Hip Hop beats.
They're kind of in the
vein of Flying Lotus
or even like a zombie J Dilla.
I'm really excited to
see what she does next,
so I'm definitely
keeping an eye on her,
and you should too.
Just wanted to
highlight a couple of
the transitions in the episode.
We've got a really
cool transition by an
artist called Kuhn,
also a contributor to
the Astro Nautica label.
The song is called Even Bears,
and it runs under the scene
where Amy Sedaris, our
special guest realtor,
is driving the girls from
apartment to apartment.
- (beeping) Kio robot.
(screeching tires)
- Come on, let's hurry up.
I gotta get home and
feed my Oscar fish.
- Are we just leaving it?
- One of my favorite things
about working on Broad City
is as a DJ I've been
able to pull out a lot of
exclusive, unreleased tracks
now that I've gotten them
in submission from the show.
One of these tracks is a
track called Tribal Beat V.2.
Still a demo by an artist
who's getting a lot of traction
right now named Sweater Beats.
One is transitioned right
before the creep's apartment
and I know this song
is gonna be a banger
when it comes out
later this year.
(techno music)
- Room is available now.
So this is the living room.
- Oh, man.
- And that was my last
recap for Broad City music,
episode 109, Apartment Hunters.
There's no recap for next week.
It's all classical music.
Shoutouts to Mozart,
Bach and Vivaldi.
It's been a real honor
working on Broad City,
and I'm really excited that
we're getting a second season.
Thank you so much for
watching this season.
Follow me @MattFXFXFXFX,
follow Broad City
on FaceBook, Twitter and Tumblr,
and I'll see you next time.
- [Narrator] Broad City,
Wednesdays at 10:30
on Comedy Central.